today we're talking about halo getting
new weapons and an old but new glitch as
well as going over some battlefield
mobile footage and talking about the
last of us getting new content my name
is devonte chisholm and you're watching
gamespot news
halo infinite second multiplayer
technical preview is currently live and
it didn't take long for players to
discover new weapons that had been
previously undisclosed tucked away in a
custom game settings menu is what
appears to be a full list of halo
infinite weapons there are 22 in total
and the list includes never before seen
weapons called the disrupter and the
cinder shot some fans have managed to
enable custom games in the preview build
allowing them to take the new weapons
and a few returning favorites out for a
spin from the gameplay footage the
disruptor looks to be an electricity
based firearm while the cinder shot
appears to be a forerunner type weapon
that can fire bouncing explosive balls
of energy
the new weapons aren't the only thing
fans have discovered apparently there is
the equivalent to halo 2's bxb glitch in
halo infinite at the time of this
recording so basically what that means
is you can cancel melee animations again
but this time it's byb so let me know in
the comments if you're actually going to
try this glitch and then go watch the
vod for persia stream from earlier where
she actually got the glitch to work
in other halo news infinite bots are
about to get even smarter 343 industries
has announced that the bots will
eventually be able to drive vehicles as
well as hop into a vehicle's turret and
fire at you on the go in a blog post 343
said this functionality is coming but
it's not ready yet the studio said it
collected quote tons of data and
feedback from the first halo infinite
beta test to help improve bot behavior
including the areas of movement and
combat choices with this feedback in
mind 343 will make the bots even more
lethal in the future seems like we're
getting dangerously close to those bots
gaining full consciousness and then
taking over three for three industries
stay tuned to game spot for when that
happens
to battlefield now for the first time ea
is bringing the shooter to mobile with
the game developed by the studio of a
halo co-creator the game's full release
is still some time off but ea soft
launched battlefield mobile in the
philippines and indonesia and now the
first footage of the game has emerged
the gameplay video shows combat on foot
and in vehicles while also providing a
first look at how the controls work and
how battlefield's trademark destruction
elements factor into the mobile game
battlefield mobile is free to play but
will be supported by microtransactions
the game will also have its own battle
passes that are unique to the game and
not synced with the console pc edition
of battlefield
switching gear is a little to perfect
dark because the initiative has
announced that it's partnering up with
crystal dynamics to work on the perfect
dark reboot consequently daryl gallagher
the studio head over at the initiative
was previously at crystal dynamics he
was the head of the studio working on
the tomb raider series while at square
enix he also worked on games such as
rise of the tomb raider 20 year
celebration and deus ex mankind divided
and now let's talk about the last of us
because naughty dog is gearing up to
celebrate what was previously known as
outbreak day on september 26th naughty
dog is planning to reveal quote all new
content however at the time of this
recording it's unclear what exactly that
content will be
fans can check out the announcement at
9am pt 12pm et on sunday are we finally
going to get multiplayer are we finally
going to see it this weekend
probably not i mean i could cross my
fingers all i want but i do think it's
gonna happen in its own like state of
play or something but let me know what
you think in the comments down below and
while you're there let me know what
you're playing this weekend and uh
why why you haven't invited me why why
am i not getting an invite to this this
uh this game you're playing
especially if it's multiplayer i just
don't i'm right here i don't see why
you don't just you know
[Music]
you